messieurs je suis la seule autorité dont
vous aurez besoin
je pointe vous tirez
est-ce que vous avez tué la cible là bas
les choses étaient différentes
ce qu'on sait c'est mal tu as fais ce
que tu étais censé faire pas vrai
aujourd'hui la seule personne que tu
puni c'est toi frank castle fortement de
quelque chose je veux encore les
fichiers vidéo l'armée des états unis a
fait tout un tueur à gages franck
et frank castle que je recherche le
punisher je crois qu'il sait tout sur
mon affaire
castle le dernier témoin nous pouvons
soit procéder à un grand nettoyage soit
le laisser nous détruire
vous avez tué ma famille pour m'avoir
[Musique]
y'a plus de la guerre et de la violence
centrale
je vais les faire payer
rester en dehors de mon chemin ce n'est
pas votre combat
[Musique]
il faut que je retrouve ces pourritures
et que je lecture
est-ce que ça va s'arrêter franck
vous les exposer au prochain
ge qui décide ce que c'est la vérité
qui t'es arrivé ça m'est arrivé aussi
on peut arranger tout ça
le monde doit connaître la vérité